c'est le dispositif en cas de
dépressurisation de la cabine un masque
oxygène tombera automatiquement devant
vous c'est un lieu où d'ordinaire il
n'est pas autorisé de pénétrer et
pourtant le temps d'une journée le siège
de safran aerosystème a ouvert ses
portes aux familles de ses
collaborateurs pour une visite unique de
son site et de ses activités quand vous
prenez l'avion vous avez entendu les
consignes de sécurité ou les équipages
vous parlent de des situations d'urgence
et ben tout ce que vous avez sur la
plaquette peut être fabriquée par safran
et rosystème les masques oxygène les
radeaux de sauvetage les toboggans
d'évacuation mais aussi et ça les
équipages ne vous en parlent pas des
systèmes pour la gestion du fioul du
carburant dans l'avion ou pour la
gestion des fluides dans l'avion nous
avons une très grande palette
d'activités et c'est ce que nous
présentons aujourd'hui place à la visite
des lieux et aux explications vous
pourrez tester à plaisir les masques
oxygène destinés au pilote d'avion le
masque est accessible il est rangé dans
une boîte à masque et il se met
extrêmement rapidement sur le visage
vous l'essayez il faut il faut donc vous
appuyez vous le mettez sur ça marche
avec les lunettes on a aussi des pilotes
avec des lunettes vous le mettez
[Musique]
et pour espérer normalement nos
collègues de sa franchise sont exposés
un siège de de classe à faire qui est
extrêmement confortable mais nous
montrons aussi ce que nous faisons en
termes de jaugeage de carburant nous
montrons nos ateliers nous montrons là
où on travaille tous les jours et c'est
aussi l'occasion de rentrer dans les
ateliers dans lesquels d'habitude on ne
peut rentrer que si on est spécialement
équipé avec plus de 1000 salariés sur le
site de plaisir les familles étaient
nombreuses à venir découvrir le lieu
très chouette très bien organisé puis ça
donne l'occasion à la famille surtout
aux enfants de voir où travailler leurs
parents et c'est une première une
première fois de pouvoir avoir un métier
réel ou un lieu de travail en tout cas
donc ça peut donner des idées et
peut-être créer des vocations présent à
plaisir depuis plus de 60 ans
aujourd'hui ça prend aérosystème et
leader mondial dans de nombreux domaines
comme les équipements d'urgence et les
systèmes carburants